Oh at the front I was amazing I think
most prepared me for academically prep
is the hardest academic school in a city
for the Delphia so I struggled at first
had to take Latin in Spanish as a
freshman so just being able to do that
and like I think if I've got to prep I
could got doing not do anything so I did
good academically as Georgia as well
that's our next guest yah Dre swift
talking about his experience at Saint
Joseph's Prep in Philadelphia Spanish
and Latin as a freshman get out of here
yeah it was mandatory for us
it was rough it was a mi John you know
there me
oh come on Spanish Spanish most
definitely yeah I'm with DeAndre there
you go oh yeah you know what I mean III
I had no idea they even offered Latin
anymore I didn't either until I got
there and I knew it was meant to try to
take it two years in a row when I had to
do it I had to do well the one phrase
you don't want to say to any of the
teams when you're meeting with him this
week is caveat emptor within me buyer
beware
you don't want them to stay so uh how's
it been for you so far here that's been
amazing man I don't let a process you
only get do this once so I'm just
blessed to be in his position but um
medical part is very long very long very
long days but I'm blessed test your
patience that night I think they were
think that's what they were doing and I
think part of it is they have guys
they're keeping an eye on you to see how
you react in those settings most
definitely would tell my dad I said I
think the guy was in there just looking
to see how we were react and see what we
were doing so I was trying to keep it
cool keep a smile on my face it's the
thing they watch everything that you do
I mean dumb little things like when they
come pick up at the airport for a visit
to a team whoever's driving that car is
paying close attention to everything you
say everything you do they're gonna
report back because they're looking to
get you away from saying and doing the
things that you think they want you to
see and being the real guy and and how
hard is that for you to balance I'm sure
you get plenty of advice and preparation
but for you like what's your approach
when you go in for one of these
interviews do you do you tell them what
you think they want to hear or you just
tell them whatever you think the right
answer is my kind of men myself smile
just do whatever they ask me to do
whether it's draw players on birth talk
about different protections and I'm
trying to remember their pleas as well
as these show me that just being myself
you played with both Nick Chubb and Sony
Michele at Georgia what did you learn
from watching them oh man a lot on how
to carry myself on and off the field how
to be a leader how to stay ready so I
got to get ready I'm a lot of stuff go
to them before I'll go to my coaches
because I could relate to them more
he also played with Jake from who's
going to be one of the top quarterbacks
tell me why a team would be better off
adding him than one of the other
quarterbacks in this class um man this
spirit he just comes in room lifts
everybody no matter if you having a bad
day or anything huh a great leader knows
how to take him in at a room out of
offense but a team I know I gots a
spirit um I just love him he's a great
great brother at me when did you know
you were gonna be able to play football
at an NFL level at NFL level my freshman
year in high school
I think we opened up in a Texas I guess
a nicely Drake team got to play as a
freshman and started making players
daughter succeed yeah I started
competing and I was kind of gave me a
whole black I could do this I could play
on this level well speaking of Saint
Joseph's Prep in your high school
experience we got some highlights of
DeAndre Swift in his high school days
dominating as most of these great
players usually do is that a little
swing pass you can't there and off you
go Wow and see it's the speed it's the
elusiveness it's the power and it's just
it really does stand out the great
players who make to this level it almost
it does it almost feel like it's too
easy sometimes at the high school level
looking back on it you could say that
but not not while I was in his moment we
always had great competition especially
LaSalle High School's or that rivalry
but yeah I miss high school when you get
to the college level when was that
moment that you knew this is different
than high school this isn't gonna be as
easy as it was there um first day a
training camp
um so hot cleat sweat and you can't make
moves and call your mom and just tell
her like how much everything was going
on but you kind of started thinking like
is this really something I want to do
just perseverance do that in that wild
where and you probably don't have that
happen the NFL level there's gonna be
some adversity that makes you really ask
yourself am I fully committed am I going
to do what I need to do or not and
already go through that call
prepares you for what's to come at the
NFL level because at some point I
remember stories from guys in the past
they get to their first motier practice
and they realize this this really is
fundamentally different who's been
giving you advice on what to expect when
you get to the next level a lot of
people without food that came from
Georgia and a lot my um my close friend
DJ more for the Duffy place would come
on the Panthers talk to him a lot about
highs experience was and what he's been
been into what is your target for the
forty this week I want to win a great
time four five under four five
how are you do all the workouts
everything everything's good to go
healthy ready to do I'm not benching I'm
doing everything on the field to have to
hear do you have any track background I
do I ran track when I was younger what
were your events I ran one the two in
four by one and I ran indoor like 55 and
a 60 minutes what was your best event I
would say the 60 or 55 now I hold the
record at my high school for that I
don't remember the exact time and I'm I
was pretty good in 100 I had ten ten
seven and my best time when I used to
run you know they say records are made
to be broken you kind of like holding on
to that record for as long as you can as
long as I can I know somebody's gonna
come bring me a lot of fast people there
now so long as I hold on to it I will
who's the guy when you go out into an
NFL field and you see him out there in
uniform you're gonna say I can't believe
this I can't believe I'm out here with
this guy if I ever get to be on the same
food as Tom Brady you know so many guys
have said that Tom Brady yeah somebody
guys said you could be playing with Tom
Brady you never know how it's gonna get
even though nobody that's part of the
fun of the draft the uncertainty could
be back in Philly you could be somewhere
in Georgia
you could be wherever Tom Brady is all
right we are out of time on this
Wednesday edition to pft live DeAndre
Swift thank you so much for some of your
time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports